c'est quoi pour vous un agriculteur
quelqu'un qui travaille dur
quelqu'un qui polluent non on va pas en
parler on est on a dit qu'on serait
positif donc aujourd'hui donc on va pas
parler de ça un mec sympa souvent
souvent les gens nous le disent
quelqu'un qui fabrique votre nourriture
c'est moins évident d'y penser ça tous
les goûts pour moi c'est mon métier
s'ils veulent les voilà ça c'est ma
ferme s'élève à ch
c'est sympa assez de photos comme cela
mais si vous saviez comment ces
exigences et bêtes là c'est même pas la
peine d'y penser pendant 40 ans j'en ai
vu et je vous raconte une anecdote quand
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune que j'ai
connu ma femme elle était pas de réguler
three sides et un jour de se marier puis
d'aller les folies judith uc g40
maîtresse 8 60 ans a besoin de moi la
nuit en plus bon à l'atmosphère la tête
est pas tout compris après je vais quand
même expliquer ce que c'était des
maîtresses qu'elle a besoin de moi vous
avez compris c'est elle ah oui des fois
la nuit quand elles veulent faire de
petits veaux il faut les il faut venir
les aider
et puis elle est venue travailler avec
moi c'était déjà un peu moins dur pour
pour moi d'état 2 pour pour le suivre et
on a besoin dans notre métier de numéro
2 d'un pas numérisés mais de notifier
beaucoup de choses tout ce qu'on fait
pour que le consommateur après soit sûre
de ce qu'elle a dans son assiette tout
ça c'est très normal mais c'est
contraignant ces deux ans qu'un jour on
a des outils qui ne sont venus ce soir
là ça je vous jure
vous allez pas forcément le liées à
l'agriculture un agriculteur mais pour
moi c'est extrêmement précieux qui est
toute ma ferme dedans j'ai mon troupeau
chaque vache est dedans parce que dans
toutes leurs
leur petit nom et je sais tout tout le
parcours de leur vie à travers sa côte
est n'est ce jeu les notifie dedans vous
les voyez sur des boucles dans les
oreilles donc ça ça les a tout le temps
de la vie ça va même plus loin si vous
mangez de la viande vous pouvez remonter
jusqu'à l'animal à partir de ça et donc
ça maintenant j'arrive à le faire avec
ça donc c'est très utile donc on a
rentré du numérique dans l'agriculture
mon franc le rende partout y'a rien de
bizarre à 100 alors on a fait d'essayer
des choses aussi c'est plus sympa que ça
je suis venu à m'intéresser au numérique
parce que j'aime bien communiquer savez
dans une ferme on est un peu loin de
tout un peu seul ça m'a un peu ralliée
au monde ça aussi je me suis amusé à un
moment quand un bonnet c est dire tiens
on va on va demander sur facebook
demandé sur twitter de donner un nom de
le baptiser un jour j'ai toute une
équipe de que je connaissais plus ou
moins et mieux vaut là on va l'appeler
hashtag ça allait bien c'est pas
forcément courant
leveaux hashtag vous allez voir si vous
voulez sur internet il a fait le tour du
monde parce qu'après yeux des reportages
de frais de fait c'était très marrant
tout ça donc on a bien rentré du
numérique dans l'agriculture mais
numérique c'est que ce soit pour nous ou
pour d'autres c'est des outils froids
c'est pas des enjeux c'est pas ça qui
est important pour demain ce qui est
important pour demain je pense que
faudra qu'on le voit d'un bon oeil mais
ça peut faire frémir par moments c'est
une population grandissante qu'il faudra
nourrir
alors serez-vous j'ai pas vocation à
nourrir tout le monde puis j'y arriverai
pas de toute façon même si je voulais
aussi l'aider contribué un petit peu
c'est de l'énergie qu'il faudrait de
plus en plus peut-être différente et
puis surtout c'est la planète qu'il faut
qu'on essaye de protéger si on veut la
garder encore un petit peu homogène et
ressentant je pense que j'ai fait la
plus grande partie maintenant mais quand
même faudra la laisser pour derrière
pour ceux qui viennent le premier point
premier enjeu qu'on va avoir c'est de
nourrir toute cette population on dit
comme ça on va nourrir les gens proches
de ces jeux oui sauf que vous voyez bien
sous la loupe
il ya la moitié de l'humanité qui est là
donc là en plus les terres sont pas très
fertile on se demande pourquoi ils en
étaient tous se mettre là on va avoir du
mal à nourrir tout le monde avec ce qui
pousse dans ces endroits là donc ils ont
d'autres solutions ils font un peu
d'agriculture urbaine c'est moderne
c'est bien qu'ils en ont vraiment besoin
eux de le faire il importe pour ça que
l'on travaille un petit peu aussi pour
l'exportation qui vont aussi concourir
des terres dans le reste du monde ça
s'est un peu moins marrant parce que
d'autres en ont besoin un peu où ils
sont d'autant plus que nos trente ans
c'est ça notre en temps ils sont
toujours la moitié de l'humanité
ils sont passés à 5 milliards mais
l'afrique où ils vont chercher des
terres pour se nourrir pas un milliard à
2 milliards et demi augmente de 125%
là ça change la donne ça veut dire que
80% de l'humanité et non 30 ans sera
entre tokyo et lagos au passage on
s'imagine qu'on va encore être les
patrons des moments j'en doute un petit
peu quand même qu'on va comment que on
va continuer à commander tout seul tout
ce beau monde là donc ça l'enjeu y ait
là pour nourrir tout le monde donc il
faut en tenir compte de la façon dont va
se faire donc ça va revoir les choses
deuxième gros enjeux pour demain c'est
celui là
si ça veut passer voilà c'est l'énergie
quand j'avais pour votre j'étais un peu
plus jeune en 1970 on était 3 milliards
7 sur terre ont consommé chacun une
tonne 350 d'équivalent pétrole
en 2000 on était déjà plus de 6
milliards on en consomme une tonne et
demie en 2035
on sera plus de 8 milliards en
consommant chacun deux tonnes en 60 ans
on a ramé multiplier par trois la
consommation énergétique sur la planète
est la plus grande partie n'est pas
renouvelable
résultat il sera là et pour besoin de
vous faire de commentaire vous le savez
comme moi
c'est assez dramatique le schéma sa déco
de soi même falloir trouver des
solutions alors trouver des solutions à
son où je pense qu'il faut qu'on les
voie positive évidemment est-ce qu'on a
une partie de la solution dans notre
métier je pense objectivement je le
pense je pense que l'agriculture sera
une des solutions aux problèmes de
demain demain on devra continuer à
produire de la nourriture mais je pense
qu'on pourra aussi être producteur
d'énergie on a déjà un peu commencé on a
plein de bâtiments dans nos fermes
c'est autant d'endroits pour mettre du
photovoltaïque on n'aime pas trop mettre
sur la terre parce que ce canton nommé
sous la terre baissé autant de terres
cultivables en moins donc on aime bien
le mettre sur les toits mais peu moins
c'est dans nos campagnes de nos champs
comme et aussi des éoliennes
il ya tout ce qu'on peut faire avec des
déchets pour faire du
du méthane qui apprend transforme en
énergie dont il ya plein de possibilités
dans lesquels on peut s'investir
donc c'est un bon débouché mais le plus
magique qu'on peut faire c'est capté du
carbone par les plantes
la plante est le plus bel le plus beau
capteur de capot de carbone qui est
qu'est pu être créés savait que les
plantes se nourrissent de carbone par la
photosynthèse suffit de les faire
pousser du dynamiser ça et on sera des
capteurs de carbone c'est un des enjeux
majeurs de demain et pour arriver à tout
ça il va falloir changer d'autre chose
effectivement je pense que numérique
pourra nous aider alors on s'imagine des
fois le numérique c est fait pour des
grandes exploitations hypermoderne très
industrielle non le numérique qui sera
pour toutes les agricultures
je vais régulièrement en afrique je peux
vous dire qu'en afrique les pour la
petite agriculture mais j'aime pas qu'on
parle de petite ou de grande parce que
c'est pas des choses forcément
intéressante à voir comme ça l'est le
numérique est important c'est important
pour eux pour pour vendre c'est
important pour eux pour pour savoir dans
leur dialecte à eux comment mettre en
place telle et telle technique c'est
énorme
jusqu'ici on pouvait pas le faire
maintenant avec de l'intelligence
artificielle on peut traduire dans des
dialectes donc c'est cdc c'est très
basique mais c'est des choses qui
répondent à des vrais besoins donc le
numérique va nous aider là dessus je
pense qu'un des éléments il veut nous
aider le plus c'est celui là je
schématise comme ça avec une pomme donc
un produit de l'agriculture produits
alimentaires sur un livre pourquoi un
livre parce qu'on va passer une culture
au groupe beaucoup plus intensive que
celle qu'on a maintenant ne sera plus
intensives ont eu une utilisation
d'intrants à serait intensive une
utilisation de connaissances on a
sûrement utiliser beaucoup des intrants
qu'on avait notre disposition on n'a
sûrement pas utiliser un pour cent des
connaissances que la nature peut nous
apporter et ça y'a pas un cerveau humain
les gamins de le faire tout seul donc le
numérique va nous y aider l'intelligence
artificielle va nous y aider
et ça on le fera pas chacun dans notre
ferme c'est pour ça je crois beaucoup
dans l'agriculture collaborative parce
que c'est ensemble qu'on arrivera à le
faire il ya deuxième élément sur lequel
ça va nous aider c'est pour créer du
lien avec vous
consommateurs s'inquiètent de ce qu'on
met dans son assiette c'est normal parce
que souvent ça s'arrête au supermarché
derrière c'est flou on se doit de
recréer du lien avec vous et on a
maintenant ces outils-là exceptionnelles
pour assurer la traçabilité qui vous
permettront demain de savoir exactement
de shekels agriculteurs via le produit
que vous avez ça c'est magique mais ça
on va devoir construire ensemble je
crois pas qu'il ya ce qu'ils feront
et puis ceux qui seront moi j'ai besoin
de vous
j'ai pas besoin vous veniez me dire
comment faire non j'ai besoin que vous
veniez construire avec moi construire ce
que sera cette agriculture de demain ce
qu'on sent monfroy pour mettre dans
votre assiette
j'ai besoin qu ensemble demain on a ici
mais des choses il ya quelques années
j'avais un blog j'ai plus trop le temps
de m'en occuper ou tous les dimanches
matins j'écrivais à billets 30 ans
j'écrivais des poèmes je suis allé
rechercher pour préparer pour
aujourd'hui
et puis j'ai retrouvé quelque chose que
j'avais écrit à cette saison à peu près
je vais vous le dire je ne connais pas
par coeur et on est à la saison où on
sème le blé
c'est la saison des semailles dans les
villes et les champs quel que soit votre
vie il est des grains de blé partout à
mettre en terre le temps est au sommeil
il est à l'engagement c'est le temps de
l'espoir
le temps des prévisions le temps de la
patience des jours de grands flux main
c'est le temps de l'hiver et la terre
s'assoupit le grain veille périr mais
1,6 accomplir ce mais c'est entreprendre
c'est assumer un risque sur soumettre
aux destins mêlés des temps qu'on peut
semer s'est s'inquiété ne jamais le
montrer accepté d'assumer et se remettre
en cause
refuser de subir et forcer le destin
alors oui vous avez vous aussi dès
demain des champs de blé à les semer
pas forcément dans des champs pas
forcément les mêmes grain meyer a besoin
de ces graines la has mais pour que
demain ensemble ont réussi ce pari
et puis là vous verrez
vous verrez un moment que au delà du blé
qui pousse il faut aller voir plus loin
que l'horizon que des horizons il faut
aller voir ce qui pousse derrière c'est
à dire l'énergie qu'on va pouvoir
produire le carbone qu'on va capter s'en
va le faire ensemble on va le faire en
apportant toutes ces nouvelles
technologies
et puis vous verrez qu'avec les
nouvelles technologies le numérique fera
de l'agriculteur d'agriculture une vraie
valeur et phrases l'agriculteur un
transmetteur de bien merci
[Musique]